well today is the start of king week in
the city of las vegas there are lots of
events planned to recognize the great
works of civil rights leader martin
luther king jr bianca holman is live to
tell us more about it sounds like going
to be a lot of good things planned this
week bianca
hey good morning sherry there sure are
so many events planned this weekend next
week to celebrate the life of dr martin
luther king jr and also to know that
it's been 40 years that we've had a
parade to celebrate his life and his
legacy here in las vegas and while there
are lots of things happening to
commemorate his life there's lots of
things happening here in the historic
west side leaders in las vegas want to
ensure black history is preserved the
historic west side legacy parked it
recently opened about a month ago it's
located on mlk in lake mead this honors
36 trailblazers and more will be added
throughout the years this park is just
the beginning of all the work planned
for the area
the landscape of the historic west side
in the next five to ten years will be
completely different to what it is now i
think we have advancements in our
housing
development that are taking place we'll
have more restaurants we'll have other
businesses taking place we're in the
process of taking jackson avenue which
is one of the the original
main streets right in the core of this
request side we're putting a lot of
money into revitalizing that street a
complete street program
and so you just heard from councilman
creer he also spoke about an intense
plan to help re-energize the area that's
where he's from born and raised and
still resides there now and from the
historic west side signs that are there
now the workforce development programs
the beautification grants it's helping
to keep people in the community and
there's also the workforce development
center he tells me that it's going to be
under construction later this year it's
going to be located right next to the
historic west side school so again lots
of things happening in that area in that
neighborhood and of course along with
several events happening at the start of
king week leading up to dr martin luther
king jr day on monday and thereafter
bianca holman live local now